肖申克的救赎自1994年上映以来，一直稳居各大影评网站top一，相信屏幕前的你已经无数次为他停留。今天我将带你从创作者的角度去剖析这部电影。
是的同学们，你们最爱的编剧拉片来了。
准备好了吗？
开始吧。
。
强调一下我们的学习目的啊，咱们不是来加片赏析的啊。首先这一件明确，我们没有那闲工夫跑这儿加片儿赏析，写影评来的不是，这是第一。第二呢，我们也不是来找吹牛的谈资的。很多同学看片子啊，喜欢看，哎呀，你知道吧？里面那只鸟啊，那只乌鸦呀是个比喻。
它比喻失去自由的人，对吧？然后后面还有个台词点睛说安底是那只关不住的鸟是吧？那个那个。
呃，其他人呢全是那种被关注的鸟，然后小老布布鲁克斯养大的那只鸟呢，就他那只鸟就代表了布鲁克斯。然后在原著当中呢，那只鸟实际饿死了，在电影当中呢没饿死。
这些东西啊啊坦白讲对于我们创作来说啊没有什么用啊，没有什么用。虽然它也是对的，但是你听我的它没有什么用，我们不研究这些呃神神叨叨的东西，我们只有一个目标，通过一部好的电影。
学会。
这种类型的故事咋写？
明白吗？就下次再碰到这类片子，有一个人被关进一个地方了，吧？一个人被关进一个束缚他的地方了。
我们就知道咋写了，正式开始上课，严肃点啊。
严肃点，老师要换严肃脸了。
正式开始上课。
今天的课程内容，我们学习肖申克的救赎这部电影的拉片啊，我们通过拉片肖申克的救赎这部电影学习创一些基本的创作思路啊，学习这类影片的创作方法以及创作要点。来开始。首先我们说一下，为什么第一部片子选了肖申克的救赎呢？因为他长期霸占。
影史排名第一是吧？管他是不是真的一定能排第一呢？人家长期霸占第一，至少证明人家肯定有资格有实力排在前几。我们可以简单聊几句它的背景。这部片子是94年的啊，我们说94年其实呃这个呃。
国内外都是电影大年啊。
嗯，94年，所以说这部片子在94年其实票房惨败，然后奖项也惨败啊。因为那几94年太可怕了，94年有什么啊，94年有这个杀手不太冷。
94年有那个低俗小说。
是吧94年其实还有那个香港电影也十分猛啊。香港电影对，94年还有阿甘正传啊，阿甘是得了最佳影片和最佳导演嘛，阿甘正传直接就封神了。神仙打架这四个字用在94年简直就是非常非常正确啊。但是嘞。
这部电影它非常的慢热啊，它在若干年以后成为了这个这个影史排名第一啊，至少评分影史排名第一的片子啊，简单了解一下，我们就开始进正式的进入片子。
拉片儿第一步很多同学拉片第一步啊，先去给一个片子找类型，先去给一个片子写一句话故事错了啊。
拉片第一步。
信息包啊信息包先给我拆信息包。
我说过一般来说一个商业电影三十几个信息包啊，一定要记住，拉片第一步先拉信息包信息包一旦拉出来以后，它是一个什么样的什么类型的电影？它的一句话是故事是什么？哎呀，跃然直上，了然于胸，一目了然是吧？根本就不需要辩论了。
根本就不需要辩论了。所以说提前去辩论这部片子一句话故事是什么？类型是什么？没有必要先拉信息包，有条件的同学记一下笔记。其实我希望所有人都记，记完了以后，等你自己再去回顾这部片子的时候，就可以拿出这个笔记，哎，对吧？熟悉一下。
第一包。
第一趴。
第一趴到这个片子的6分钟啊，写的是什么呢？写的是庭审加回忆这么一场戏，其实是为了回溯案情，主角安迪因为杀妻案疑似。
含冤被定罪，因为这里我们不完不完全知道安迪是含冤的这是个小悬念。我们要回到第一次看这个片子的时候的感觉啊，同学们啊，所以说这里是有个小悬念的，他到底有没有杀妻子，实际是。
含冤啊疑似含冤啊。
这是第一趴。
第二趴。
第7分钟啊，对德的视角red呢申请出狱，被驳回。记得啊，这是他第一次申请出狱，这也是一个名场面，后面有多次呼应，有两次呼应啊。
然后他出来以后，通过他与其他人的对话交代了一下，其他人也被驳回了。
这个也很重要啊，不光re一个人被驳回了，其他人也被驳回了。这是什么意思呢？red是这个监狱大家的一个代表啊，一个比较典型的代表。
不仅仅是一个男二号啊，它是一个典型伙伴们的伙伴群象的一个代表。这里大家记着啊，记把这个记在脑子里，待会是有用的。
然后呢，red。
介绍自己介绍监狱用的是旁白的方式啊，在第二趴就开始read有旁白了啊，用的是read这个旁白的方式啊去介绍这些东西。
然后。
第三趴。
第三趴是从第9分钟开第9分钟开始的新人入狱。大家都记得啊，那个车开过来啊，拉着新的这个犯人进来了。安迪和red相遇呃，同学们记不记得？
我在讲爱情十六字真言的时候，关于这个相遇啊，我说要有仪式感两个人相遇，最好不打不成交啊，冤家路窄是吧？或者是妻世怨侣有渊源，这里上来两个人有没有渊源？
太有渊源了吧。
那个red赌安y会第一个崩溃，压住压在他身上了。你看这是个赌局，两个人就很有很有这个很有这个渊源。
然后呢，同时也也用red的游刃有余。在这个他的这个小伙伴当中啊，是一个小老大的存在，对吧？因为他能搞到东西嘛，用他的这个游刃有余和安迪这个唯唯诺诺对吧？胆心惊胆战，细皮嫩肉，形成一个基本的互补。所以说这里既做了相遇，也做了互补。
然后同时也交代了这个监狱的基本环境啊，这里的人都是凶神恶煞的。
这是第三趴啊第三趴主要是两个人的相遇，用赌局制造两个人的相遇以及环境交代。
第四趴。
第四趴又回到安迪的视角，讲安迪融入新环境的痛苦过程，包括脱衣服呀，被人泼白泼白面湿灰消毒呀，杀的眼睛睁不开呀，对吧？被人那个身边的人因为说错一句话被打呀，我们说。
这是一个这个这个狱警啊，这是进入监狱的一个非常有仪式感的。有很多同学说，哎呀，这个镜头我见多了，其实挺俗的，你别忘了，他是第一个第四拍是12分钟啊。安迪这个融入的痛苦过程是第12分钟。
第五拍从第15分钟开始啊，第15分钟开始又安迪。
就是当天晚上，安迪没有崩溃，他一声不吭。
这里暗示了他有过人的毅力啊，就暗示了安y非池中物，他不是个善茬啊，因为他一声也不吭。这个是通过ra的旁白说了，说安迪一声没吭。但是呢那个小胖子出局了啊杀不光出局了，还被打死了。第六个节拍21分钟。
是来到了第二天的早饭，继续展现这个恶劣的环境。当然还要继续展现环境了。因为整个还在第一幕里面嘛，第一幕里面继续展现这个环境跟人的对抗，什么东西也不好吃，还得有虫子，对吧？各种展现。这里呢这一场主要是干什么呢？主要是救猫咪，我一说救猫咪啊，很多同学是不是惯性的想，哎呀，那他喂那只鸟。
他找了一个虫子喂那个老布的鸟，这是救猫咪吧。
对吧鸟儿和猫咪就产生了一个联想。
错误。
那什么是旧猫咪啊？这一场干什么是旧猫咪啊，问名字。
问名字问小胖子的名字，他是这里一个唯一尊重人的存在的人。
因为这里在不断的疯狂暗示，他是这个监狱唯一无罪的人，一个无罪的人，一个正常的人，他没有被制度化。所以他希望知道一个人的名字。而那些在这个在这个监狱里面的人呢，他觉得人的名字没有意义啊，就像95271样，每个人只是个编号而已。每个人只是一个存在一个老。
一个隔间而已，对吧？他想知道小胖子的名字展现了他的人性，展现了救猫咪啊。
当然同时也通过这个小胖子死，通过其他狱友的表现，也表现出大家其实也有尚未泯灭的人性。虽然赌博赌赢了，但是看到一个小胖子死了，大家还是难过的。
当然那只鸟啊那只鸟也有用，包括在这一场其实提前铺垫了那个姐妹团啊，我们就叫他姐妹团，你们知道那那个人就可以了啊，姐妹团也其实也提前垫了一下，呃，实际在这垫也行啊，但是略微垫的有点早呃，这呃本来应该是第二幕的啊。
但是呃咱课上也讲过，理论上反派出场越早越好，而且特别是后面呃中中间要挂掉的这种反派啊，所以说尽量早点出场，威胁拉的早一点也是没有问题的。在第一幕出没有问题啊。但是我们同学自己要知道啊，常规一般来说像姐妹团这种。
这种阻力啊一般放在第二幕开头，第七趴是第24分钟啊，洗澡的戏再次顺着上一场早饭的戏，把这个姐妹团的威胁再给了一遍。你可以理解啊，这场戏啊其实也是个小零碎儿。
为了把上一场早饭那场戏延续的这个。
危险啊再往前推一推，所以又给了一个拍啊，第八拍是25分钟，这里他强调了一个时间线，这里已经入狱一个月了，安迪干什么啊？
安迪去找re买小锤儿啊，买小锤子。
记不记得那场戏啊，安迪已经入狱一个月了，但是呢跟谁也不吭声，不说话。
突然找re的买锤子，而且这里呢这里有几个金句啊，就是关于无罪这个金句。
那个red说这里的所有人都是无罪的哈，我们这里大家都没有罪，都是冤枉的，就你一个人有罪哈。这里实际是说了个反话，只有安迪一个人没有罪，明白这个道理吧？
实际上其实整个肖申克只有安迪一个人没有罪，但是他们在这里说成了，我们都是无罪的，就你有罪啊。
然后呢，同时。
同时同时。
安迪买锤子red。
怀疑他要越狱啊，这里搞了一个小诱惑啊，实际上诱惑了一下观众啊，让观众以为他要越狱这里。但是他说你只要看到这个锤子就明白了，所以后面迅速的把这个悬念给破掉了。这里记着啊第八节拍25分钟之read在这里正式提醒他。
关于姐妹团的危险，这个危机算是正式抛出来了啊，这才是这个危机应该爆发的位置啊。我们说进入第二幕才爆危机嘛，这里是很好的位置了。
你可以理解之前铺垫了两下，让这个危机更大啊。
同时记住第八拍啊，第八拍还有一个东西要记住，就是关于锤子这件事情。
锤子是安迪的第一个需求，对探索自由的第一次尝试啊。第九拍。
通过一场一场配着背景音乐的一场相对欢快的戏。
小锤子如何到如何从外面到安迪手里的全流程给展示了一下。然后这个red看到这个锤子之后，这里做了一个预言说这个锤子要想挖墙越狱啊，需要600年啊，需要600年。嗯，把刚才。
刚刚建立起来的。
观众以为安迪要越狱这个预期。
同学们记着啊，这两个这个点非常重要啊。
我们说在第八趴的时候。
安迪买小锤子，red直接说啊，你要锤子，你要锤子，你不是要越狱吗？
这部片子的最终结局，我们知道是安迪越狱了。
但是在这里其实。
作者或者创作者是不想给观众这个预期了。
但是他不想给你。
安迪的越狱的预期，他还用一场。
他还用这么一个小预期在迅速打破这个预期，极限挑逗你。
你明不明白这个意思啊？他在极限挑逗你相当于什么啊？相当于假设这个创作者本来是想追你，想跟你在一起想泡妞，对吧？
但是呢他假装对你有好感，然后又迅速让你以为是个误会。
你看他多坏。
这就是高手的玩法。如果按照正常创作来说，我们不想让观众提前知道安迪要越狱，那么我们前面最好就不要给这方面的预期这里。
刚才有个同学说的非常好啊，说这叫游戏时间，表扬一下这位同学嗯，这一场戏确实是监狱生活的一种一个切片啊。因为进到监狱里面，我们说虽然很苦，但是总要抽烟，总要洗澡，总要看小小黄书的呀。那这些东西哪来的呢？它通过一个很俏皮的过程。
展现这个全过程，满足大家对监狱生活的一个想象。我们说这一定程度上这里确实是游戏时间啊扬。
第十趴31分钟，我们说这场戏你给我记住记着一下，非常重要。
这里姐妹团攻击安迪。
开始攻击安迪，而且不是一揍他一次。
是经常的打他，经常的侵犯他。
我们说这场戏是什么？
也是蒙太极剪辑。
这是游戏时间。
不要字面理解游戏时间是做游戏啊。
游戏时间是符合观众对监狱生活的想象和预期呀。
所以你看上一场用很轻快的音乐用蒙太奇剪辑展示了监狱里面的人怎么搞到违禁品，怎么搞到香烟，怎么搞到海报，怎么搞到小锤子，怎么搞到业余爱好。然后这一场呢又用蒙太奇的很轻快的方式展现一个新人进到监狱以后，要被那些老老。
老玻璃给揍给欺负。
这不都是我们对于一个美国监狱的想象吗？
这不都是海报上应该出现的内容吗？
游戏时间是观众对一个影片的基本预期啊。
来十一把。
修理屋顶33分钟修理这个屋顶这个任务啊，伙伴们拿下来了，带着安迪上去。我们可以理解啊，开始互助了啊。
我们说。
护住了以后呢。
这个这个安迪呢帮助那个狱警解决了一个。
税务问题，然后以此获得了冰啤酒，而且这个冰啤酒呢是回馈伙伴们，因为他自己啊并不喝酒。
那至于他自己并不喝酒，他为什么要去？
做这件事情冒着生命危险换来冰啤酒呢，电影当中啊非常直白的用台词表达出来，说他想再次品尝自由的味道。
记不记得用台词非常直白的表达了他想再次品尝自由的味道。
记住啊记住这个关键点。